sincerely congrats on this movie
um uh it made me very angry and I and uh
I don't know based on the material and
what and you know
um is going off on the rails let me let
me actually ask a real question
um
the thing that I really enjoyed about
this is that it doesn't focus on
Charlie's uh you know what he's doing
behind the scenes and being violent and
trying to like go after the his
perspective it's instead focusing on the
heroes and you know and I I really dug
that aspect of the film can you sort of
talk about that yeah I have trouble
sometimes with the real crime genre I
find that it becomes quite fetishistic
in the way that they sensationalize
violence uh it feels a bit uncomfortable
for me
um to spend so much time focusing on the
life of someone who caused so much pain
to others and what was so beautiful
about working on this and it's to be as
lindholm's humanity and you see it in
all of his work is that he said you know
I'm going to focus now on the person who
stopped the violence and she's not she
didn't stop it with violence she stopped
it with compassion and love and
friendship and reminding him
um of the person he is and he's not a
monster he did terrible things but he
saved her life and he's also done good
things and by by focusing on that kind
of compassion and love uh she was you
know the cycle of violence then ends and
how great to be a part of a real crime
genre film that focuses on that and lets
everyone that's watching it at home know
that they can also step forward and be
the individual that is able to combat a
system when you think that maybe you
might have no power in doing so Eddie of
I'll ask you an individual question um
you've never played a dark character
like this
um was it something that at the end of
the shoot you were completely ready to
shed or were you like I think I'm going
to be playing some dark characters going
forward oh um but you know the
interesting thing about the the playing
of him is we were lucky enough to spend
time with that the real Amy Locker in in
prep for the film and you know she spoke
uh about
these two different human beings that
she knew one was her best friend or
close friend who was a kind
generous brilliant nurse who saved her
life and then this other person that she
met twice that was a serial killer who
was a completely different human being
and she really underlined the importance
of the friendship and the truth of that
friendship and so what it meant about
the making of the film is a large amount
of it you know Jess was having to play
Amy's heart condition she was having to
run around the set to build up her heart
rate it was an extraordinary physical
feat and actually for a lot of the film
my role was was really
playing her friend
um and it was only those last few weeks
of filming when
my family went home that it became more
intense and rigorous and but even those
scenes which were based on some of the
verbatim text that he said like
it was it was
um extreme but it was also getting to do
that with Jess who's an old friend and
an actor I've long admired was kind of
thrilling as well uh Jessica you have
played a number of real people but I
believe this is the first time the real
person was on set oh yeah that's a
nightmare
no it's uh I mean it's great to have the
to be able to talk to the person that
you're playing and she was so incredibly
generous with me and what a resource but
of course I'm human and I get really
intimidated and I can do all my prep
before and then when I get on set I want
to just kind of fall into the story I'm
playing so every time I saw her I just
was like oh yeah I'm a fraud that's Amy
not me
um I was really intimidated by her being
there but she was so generous with me
she you know we we give each other a hug
and then she kind of like hide from my
sight so I would almost forget she was
there
um yeah she was great you guys had the
fortune of filming most of this movie in
order and I wanted to know what was that
like as an actor and do you feel that
does that really help you with your
performance absolutely absolutely always
and also in the delicacy of what this
friendship was the bits that we could
shoot in order with all the Interiors
inside the hospital and one of the
things I love about Christy Wilson
kearns's script is that she doesn't
overwrite there's a sparse to teach she
has like a real faith in the in the
actors but when you're shooting
chronologically you can develop little
things that then get paid off later that
that and also your friendship or your
character's friendship progresses is
naturally is it's such a rare thing but
it's extraordinary when when you can
have it I always love learning about
like how you get ready for a shoot and
because I really do enjoy both of your
work did you
um how did you actually both uh how long
do you spend for a performance like this
how long before your shooting begins are
you actually getting in the headspace is
it like months is it weeks like how does
it actually work I start getting in the
headspace as soon as I know that the
movie's gonna happen or that the
Project's gonna happen I mean I was
shooting scenes from a marriage and it
kind of like really came right up into I
finished scenes from a marriage and in
fact we had dinner with Tobias Lindholm
when he when he came to town Oscar and
his wife and Jeremy like we all met with
Tobias to um welcome him to New York and
then we started rehearsals
for this it was kind of like a right
into thing and it couldn't have been
more of a different kind of headspace
but we were we had been attached to this
project for like six years
um so we knew it was gonna happen for a
long time we had plenty of time to read
the book The good nurse the Charles
Draper's book that it's based on you
know or the true story is based on but
the that great resource
um to go to to talk to Amy uh we went to
nursing school we met in tobias's
kitchen for like weeks you know going
through the dialogue line by line I mean
we really
did a lot before we ended up on set yeah
and I I I'm I'm not I'm like one of
those actors that like
if I attach myself to something
particularly something like this that
shoots abroad or whatever like the
second I'm attached to it it's in my
head and it's and I don't attach myself
to something and I I find that hard to
touch yourself to things without going
oh yeah I'm definitely doing this and so
weirdly I live with it this one we lived
with quite a long long time
um but also since The Theory of
Everything which was the first time when
I was allowed a long
um Runway I suppose you know a long
period of time to prep it's become like
a thing that I you know will always push
for because some actors can jump into
accents and physicalities and stuff and
and for me it takes a a wee while for
those things to they can work
cosmetically for a while but to be
embedded so um I was very grateful on
this that we had that time yeah and that
no need to stop I'm just gonna say
congrats on the movie uh and thank you
for giving me your time good luck with
the rest of your speed dating thank you